welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss in we have a new trailer for thor
love and thunder which chris hemsworth
promised would would blow our minds the
bar has been set but you know the drill
i'm gonna react to it in real time give
you my first impressions of it cover
some of the highlights and then tomorrow
will be my in-depth frame by frame
easter egg breakdown i'm gonna be
working through the night for you
because i love you the the kind of the
kind of love that thought told me i have
to sidle in through the side of the
frame because i love you that's why i
always make direct eye contact
because because the star lord said you
must always just look into the eyes of
the one you love
that's that's me and you bitty all right
let's take a look here we
go
kids get to popcorn now let me tell you
the story of the space viking thor
odinson
he was no ordinary man
he was a god
after saving planet earth for the 500th
time thor set off on a new journey
someone was removed from that petery
bill was there he went from dead bod
to godbod
and after all that
he reclaimed his title
as the one and only four
oh spook too soon
jane
this helmet looks so stupid
it looks so great
the old ex-girlfriend
a family three four years
eight years seven months and six days
for divorce
my uh sensing feelings
[Music]
well you're right
who's the only ones who gods care about
is themselves
whoa so this is my vow holy [ __ ] he
looks great
oh god she will die
oh my god he looks amazing
i just want to say that was very very
impressive what you did back there
[Music]
she's just my first bad guy
[Music]
you never forget your first
[Music]
doing this like frank miller [ __ ] this
is great
this movie looks incredible let's see
who you are and take off your disguise
what is that accent flick
you flick too hard damn it
[Laughter]
should we help him eventually grape
i want to be one of those great
let's go so i am obsessed with the look
of gore the god butcher right now choice
to introduce him in this trailer in high
contrast monochrome the black and the
white making all the lines of his face
his lips his dead eyes popping off the
screen while at the same time looking so
much like jason aaron's comics the only
color they give him are just these
piercing yellow eyes i'm telling you i i
don't mean to be referencing frank
miller another comic book artist
obviously he has written so many other
things other than this but the visuals
here remind me so much of the high
contrast photography of sin city it
looks so great and it and it just it
like
and it like devours your soul as you're
sucked into this despair with gore i
mean this is like what voldemort should
have looked like instead of you know
them sticking with
the description of him having no nose he
looks terrifying so just so that we're
all on the same page gore the godbutcher
is a serial killer who has made it his
mission to seek out all uh deity figures
throughout the galaxy and murder them
brutally he lost his family after
praying to the gods and obviously his
prayers were not answered now we still
don't know fully exactly what uh
christian bale's mcu version of gore the
god butcher what his backstory was i'm
assuming that uh some celestial event
the cracking open of a planet that
planet's doom might have been what
inspired gore's whole crusade now
there's this one interesting shot in
here with a jane foster powering up
mjolnir in this uh interesting hall
that's definitely the living tribunal on
the right there i want to say that's red
skull on the left or it could just be
death you know that bald figure next to
the living tribunal could that be a
watcher could that be uwatu or some
other watcher could we be looking at the
mcu depictions of eternity and infinity
you know on the morag temple in the
opening of the guardians of the galaxy
there were uh there were four cosmic
entities depicted in that art surrounded
by the infinity stones those four
figures were eternity infinity death and
entropy those could be the four figures
depicted here along with the living
tribunal on the side the living tribunal
again the ultimate cosmic authority over
all legal matters just made a cameo and
doctor strange the multiverse of madness
as well as loki now we don't know if
these figures will actually show up in
this movie or is it or this is just a
location that uh pays tribute to all of
them in statue form in fact this could
actually be a crypt or uh some kind of
temple within olympus which is the
pantheon of all the gods the gods who we
actually see face to face here russell
crowe as zeus who uh flicks thor too
hard
yeah we know what it looks like when you
put an l and an i next to each other
makes a u i gotta hand it to russell
group sounds like he's going for a greek
accent there zeus is a greek god i love
the commitment and one thing i want to
point out about this trailer i didn't
mention before with gore his sword is
called all black the necro sword it is
an ancient very important sword to
marvel lore at least in the comics it is
the sword that was connected to the
symbiote deity of no null used this
weapon to decapitate the celestial
nowhere here it doesn't look like a
crazy shape-shifting sword it looks like
just a classic medieval broadsword which
i really really love i don't need
another weird crazy cgi weapon now it
may have some shape-shifting properties
if we're just not seeing this trailer
but for now it's just the kind of weapon
that you could imagine clashing against
stormbreaker or mjolnir now interesting
to note that in this amazing looking
black and white battle this melee with
all these characters valkyrie is totally
engaging gore using one of zeus's
lightning bolts almost as like a way of
saying maybe assuming zeus goes down in
this movie his weaponry can still be
used by others and notice how when she's
holding it in her left hand the rest of
her body's in black and white this
source of light is what is giving color
to this scene i did not expect to have
such a dynamic and bold use of color in
this movie like are we looking at
something to where the murder of all
these gods is what drains color from the
universe am i overthinking it i mean i
really hope not
now it's not really seen in frame in
this trailer but sitting in the row in
front of valkyrie and jane that is
bossed or busted confirmed by the
actor's own casting listing i made a
whole other video explaining how this
really connects with moon knight and
with black panther mythology with
eternals potentially we're not yet sure
if the mcu is going to say that bastet
of egyptian mythology and bost of
wakanda mythology are the same character
but it is worth noting that in the mcu
chronology wakandan mythology was really
the first mythology that existed on the
planet earth but schengen consumed the
heart-shaped herb in 10000 bc which was
thousands of years before the egyptians
were on the map with their culture so it
could just be that what kind of
mythology inspired the rest of it and
that bost and bastet are in fact the
same entity we don't know that for sure
yet don't come at me saying i'm getting
wrong this is all fictional religions
and the mcu is always constantly
changing the mythology even from the
comics so we're figuring it out as we're
going so for all my big impressions it
seems like another funny scary horny
thor movie and i'm here for it christian
bale might be the most exciting villain
we have seen in this mcu and i think
what's most excited about it well they
certainly make a lot of visual choices
with how they put them on screen they're
not creating a cgi version of him it's
really just makeup and photography black
and white photography there's something
so classic and simple and elegant and
really frightening about seeing this
guy's face on screen the fact that we
can see each of the contours of his face
as it bends in pain just reminds me so
much of seeing heath ledger in black and
white makeup you know look i'm gonna
spend all night just staring at this
finding things to say about it but no
seriously i do have to go back through
this frame by frame because there's all
kinds of interesting goodies that i
can't wait to break down in the
breakdown a reminder that the best way
to support a rockstars is to check out
our merch options in new
rockstarsmerch.com if you live in the
san francisco bay area i'm performing
improv every other saturday including
this saturday may 28th with endgame's
improv at the stage works theater on
valencia street in the mission it's a
lot of fun we have fun and you can meet
me and we get drinks afterwards unless
you're weird or
or you want to beat me up over a past
theory if that's the case ignore
everything i said anyway stay tuned for
the breakdown coming tomorrow follow me
idiot boss on instagram and twitter
follow new rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for analysis of everything you
love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you